nadia était bien préparé ce matin pour
passer la tante de plus de deux heures
en tout confort en fait mon fils a été
malade la semaine dernière donc j'ai
chopé ça crève mais c'était impossible
de le faire tester parce qu'on va pas
imposer trois heures de queue à un
enfant de 7 ans donc on l'a mis en
quarantaine préventives et puis de toute
façon les résultats des tests c'est
tellement long que en gros là je vais me
faire tester c'est juste pour moi quoi
elle n'aura les résultats de son test
pcr que dans huit jours
de telles scènes sont monnaie courante
en france surtout dans les grands
centres urbains
cette semaine plus de 1 million 200
mille tests ont été réalisés dans le
pays
les différents acteurs engagés sur le
terrain ont bien du mal à suivre le
rythme non content de matériels que de
personnel c'est colossal jamais on
n'aurait pu imaginer que les gens se
ferait des pistes est aussi facilement
en quoi et je pense que on n'a pas pris
peut-être assez la mesure 2
de ceux de cette densité en test qui et
je dirai très très dur à gérer même pour
nous et même temps un je parle pas
simplement des programmes des problèmes
au niveau des automates ou des réactifs
mais humainement
la tension est palpable pour désengorger
les centres de prélèvements dès la
semaine prochaine des centres seront
ouverts pour traiter les cas
prioritaires c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
mais du même souffle il rappelle aux
français que de tester trop souvent ne
sert à rien que la pcr n'est pas en soi
un geste barrières selon cette doctrine
de priorisation des tests de les
français qui ont une prescription
médicale les personnes symptomatique les
cas contactez les soignants et les aides
à domicile passeront devant les autres
comme les voyageurs qui ont besoin d'un
test négatif à destination la haute
autorité de santé vient tout juste de
donner le feu vert aux tests salivaires
plus rapide et confortable mais un peu
moins efficace pour les personnes qui
présentent des symptômes uniquement
alors que la france enregistre
aujourd'hui pour la première fois une
augmentation du nombre de morts de
lakovic depuis le déconfinement le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron n'a pas
l'intention de revoir cette stratégie du
tester tracé isolé mais il fait fausse
route croit cet épidémiologiste c'est
une stratégie qui ne fonctionne pas
puisqu'elle n'est pas adapté au type de
virus qu'on a ou type d'épidémie en fait
cette épidémie il ya trop d'armes
automatiques et comme le tester tracé
isolé ça consiste à diagnostiquer des
gens qui sont symptomatiques et ensuite
de remonter les chaînes de contamination
si vous avez trop dassin d'automatique
vous n'arrivez pas à remonter l'échelle
de contamination et l'épidémie peut
progresser malgré le fait que vous
isoler les quelques personnes
asymptomatiques
c'est qu'ils fonctionnent en revanche ce
sont les gestes barrières comme le port
du masque dit il
quant à lui mais beaucoup comme
jacqueline 76 ans se présente sur les
sites de dépistage sans raison
particulière
non je suis pas inquiète non parce que
j'ai pas de contact hormis mon neveu
donc il n'ya pas de soucis comme tout le
monde je dirais non on doit être en
sécurité
c'est pour elle être en sécurité c'est
être testée ici marie-eve bédard
radio-canada en région parisienne